[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- It has been one of the most
successful shows on Broadway.
- It's the hottest ticket.
- One of my favorite
Broadway shows.
- 19 different productions
around the world
in seven languages.
- Simply the most
astounding and phenomenal
theatrical experience
you will ever have.
- One of the great
hit shows of all time.
- The most unique
show ever performed.
- Remarkable experience.
Most fantastic show.
- 63 million people.
- And it's truly
become a phenomenon.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[MUSIC - "THE CIRCLE OF LIFE"]
- By the summer of 1994,
"Lion King" is a giant hit.
And because it's existed as
a film, as books, as music,
it ends up in people's homes
and then touches them so much
because of its
theatrical experience.
- The question was, how does the
audience know where to focus?
The dimensionality of
theater allows the audience
to focus on the puppet and
forget about the puppeteer.
I believed in that.
As a director, you're always
looking for the abstraction
of what the whole is.
It's the circle.
It's the circle of life, it's
the sun, it's Mufasa's head.
- If you look in Julie's
original designs for the mask,
you'll see a series of circles.
And then this is how she
interpreted that design
into a physical mask
when she sculpted it.
- One of the reasons why
the "Lion King" worked
was that it was a
good collaboration.
- Lebo M's influence on this
project was so enormous.
- Everybody has that deep
emotional reaction to it.
I mean, people start crying
at the opening of the play.
I have never seen
anything like it.
- The idea of having to
put a wildebeest stampede
on the stage, yes,
I'd love to try that.
- People who have touched the
"Lion King" and its texture,
this tapestry of the Lion
King, are deeply moving to me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I would love to come back and
see it again like five times
over.
- Wow.
That's all I can say is wow.
- I loved it.
All the songs, the
music, it was great.
- Every time you see it,
you see something new.
- We're going to pick one of
you to be in "The Lion King"
tonight.
- Please welcome the
cast of "The Lion King."
And now, a special performance
from "The Lion King."
- You know, I can't hear
the beginning of that song
without crying.
- An all new Oprah.
- The spectacular "Lion King."
- Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
- The king has returned!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The Lion King has been
roaring on Broadway,
and there are currently
seven productions
running around the world.
- It is time.
- Remember who you are.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome to the stage
the cast of "The Lion King."
Bongi Duma, Lindiwe Dlamini,
Mdu Madela, Nteliseng Nhkela,
Joel Karie, Adrienne
Walker, Tshidi Manye,
and Michael Henry.
[MUSIC - "HE LIVES IN YOU"]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: We're so
pleased to welcome
our moderator for this special
"Talks at Google" event.
You loved him in "In The
Heights" on Broadway,
he was Tony nominated
for his role
as George Washington in a little
musical you might have heard of
called "Hamilton," and
currently stars on the CBS hit
show "Bull," and of course,
one of the original cast
members of "The Lion King,"
please join me in welcoming
Christopher Jackson.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS JACKSON: Thank you
very much for having me
here today, Google!
Somebody told me when I
was walking in here that I
shouldn't say, hey, Google.
That something
crazy would happen.
But you turned your phone off,
phone's off already, right?
Thought I was going to be funny.
OK, good night.
In the last 100 years,
more than 10,000 shows
have opened on Broadway.
Do you know how many
of them have run longer
than "The Lion King?"
Two.
Here are a few
other amazing things
you didn't know about
"The Lion King."
Tonight the cast will
play performance 8,338.
Placed end to end, that's
like playing "The Lion
King" 24 hours a day,
seven days a week,
from right now until March--
March of 2020.
The show's played on every
continent except Antarctica,
because penguins.
And 90 million people
have seen the show,
more than the populations of
Switzerland, Ireland, Portugal,
and Britain combined.
That's a lot of people.
Thank you for having
me here today.
Can we give it up for
our wonderful cast?
[APPLAUSE]
So one more thing
that you may not know.
One of the performers
up here today
opened "The Lion King" with me
at the New Amsterdam theater
in 1997.
She performed in
the show last night
and has been there for
everything in between.
Lindiwe Dlamini.
Now, it says here on this cue
card that I can tell a personal
opening anecdote here about
his-- my experience-- his,
mine--
experience with the show.
I was 21 when I was hired
for "The Lion King,"
and I think rehearsals had
been going on for about, what,
three days?
Three days before I,
on the fourth day,
was hired an hour before
the first rehearsal.
And that was how my
Broadway career started.
Tom Schumacher walked up
to me after my callback,
and then the room
says, congratulations,
you just booked your first show.
You have an hour before
you have to report
to rehearsal upstairs.
[SCREAMS]
So I called my mother who was
teaching school at the time,
and I made the secretary patch
my call into her classroom.
And I said, mom,
I'm on Broadway.
I don't know what that means.
I don't know what "The
Lion King" is really
going to-- what
to expect, but I'm
going to be in a Broadway show.
And she said,
[SCREAMS],, and her class
probably got out of a
lot of homework that day.
Tom Schumacher, the
producer of "The Lion King,"
says that it's a show that
speaks to everyone because it's
about what happens on
Earth after we leave it.
The song that
performed just now,
"He Lives in You," and the
reprise, "They Live in You,"
is a perfect example
of this sentiment.
Why is it that you think
that this show resonates
with so many people?
ADRIENNE WALKER: Well,
I'm going to have
to borrow something that Julie
Taymor said earlier this week.
CHRIS JACKSON:
Always a good thing.
ADRIENNE WALKER: She came
by to visit the cast,
and she kind of gave us
some motivational words,
and talked about the
process when it first began.
And she said something
that stayed with me,
and that's that the show--
the story is something that
everyone can relate to.
No matter their
background, no matter
where they're from,
no matter their age,
they can relate to some
part of that story.
And I think that's why
it's had such longevity.
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah.
TSHIDI MANYE: And
I guess to add on
that is, you know, "Lion King"
is not one of your stories,
like you know, "Cinderella"
and all of that.
This is a story about the life
that you live in, the sadness.
We've all gone through sadness,
we've all gone through--
at times we've gone through
betrayal in our lives.
And there's love
into the story, too.
So it's the life that we all
are living in everyday life.
CHRIS JACKSON: Are
there any examples
of the sadness, or the
joy in which the show now
speaks to you?
Have you guys
experienced that either
in performing the show,
or just the parallels
that you found in life?
MICHAEL HENRY: I lost my sister
to a bone cancer last year.
And the first
performance back going
into the show, when
Mufasa's singing to his son,
and he's talking to his
son about how one day he's
going to die.
But if you look into
the stars, you'll
be able to see not
only me, but you
will be able to see
everyone who has
come before me-- my parents,
their parents before them.
So I thought I was
going to be OK,
and I just was breaking
down while singing the song.
But then when it came around
again to do the reprieves,
"They Live in You,"
or "He Lives in You,"
sorry, I saw this
light come out.
And I just looked at it,
and started to spread.
I was like, that's my sister
right there, telling me
it's going to be OK.
She's with me, and she's
always going to be with me.
And she's in me right now.
And from that moment on, I
think I understood the show
on a deeper level.
Just it's a beautiful show.
But once you experience loss, it
speaks to you on another level.
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah.
LINDIWE DLAMINI: For me I think
I have the similar situation
like Michael.
I've already lost three
members of my family
while I'm in the
show for 20 years.
And being part of
this family, you
have people who support you when
you're going through something.
I remember we were
at half hour call
just before we go on stage,
and the stage manager
came in the dressing
room while I'm
putting on makeup, ready to go.
And then they told me the news
that my father has passed right
before I go on stage.
And I remember that day
I was really doubting,
I was just torn apart.
And I know my father was
very supportive of me
as a young girl
from South Africa.
He let us leave South Africa
at the age of 18 years
old to come to the States
to pursue our career.
So I know that if I
don't perform that day,
I just wanted to
feel his presence.
And I know that when I
go on, he will be happy.
If I didn't go on, that's
not what he wanted me to do.
So I went on on
stage that day, and I
remember doing-- it
was hard to do eulogy.
There's a eulogy scene when--
you know, Mufasa's death.
And then it was hard,
but I kept going.
And then we came on started
singing "He Lives in You."
And at that moment,
you know, I just--
I remember just looking at the
audience and I saw a vision.
I saw somebody sitting
in the audience.
And I kept blinking because I
was thinking, that's my dad.
You know, immediately
I connected with that.
And then as soon
as we do reprise,
I had so much joy because that
number in the show uplifts
people, you're
dancing, you're happy.
You're letting the
audience know that
no matter what happens to
you, it's going to be OK.
You know, it's a circle
of life, you know?
We all move on, and
people are born.
I experienced the
birth of my daughter
while I was in the show.
So for me, it's been both
happy times and sad times.
But because "Lion King" is a
circle of life, it keeps you--
I know a lot of
people experience
that in the audience in
other similar situations.
CHRIS JACKSON: I had a--
I think remembering, we
were performing in 2001 when
September 11th happened, and we
were off, I think, for a couple
of days.
All of Broadway shut down.
And then we opened back
up, and up until the time
at the New Amsterdam theater,
there was never an empty seat.
Never ever.
There were people waiting
outside in case somebody had
to go home in the middle of
the show to get in the theater.
And that first show
back after 9/11,
and there were maybe 1,000
people in the audience,
and the orchestra
not full whatsoever.
Playing Simba and having
to sing "Endless Night,"
where has the starlight gone?
Dark is the day.
And then seeing the conductor
try to hold it together
and losing, and me try
to hold it together.
By the time you get
through that song,
I know that the night must end,
I know that the sun will rise.
Any time art, I find, gives you
an immediate sort of context
by which you can process
all of it-- doesn't heal it,
doesn't fix it, but it creates
a means by which you can just go
through the experiencing
of all of that,
it's so cathartic and it's so--
it can be uplifting.
At the very least it
can be comforting you
while you process
through these things.
MDU MADELA: And on top of
that, we have had a few--
you know, it shows an
educational element
of the show, a few parents
bringing in their kids.
I think it must be
the first time there's
a medium of educating
a kid about loss,
about something will
happen later on.
Whether it doesn't
happen now, you
remember when
granddad passed away,
this is what had happened.
So it becomes a huge
educational element also.
BONGI DUMA: And there's also--
as you know, South
Africa plays a big part
in "The Lion King" because
of the music and culture.
For some of us,
our generation, we
were not able to
express ourselves
through art during Apartheid.
So we started acting and singing
in small churches, and schools,
and everything.
That as far as we could go.
And for us, some of
us were motivated
to use the tools
of theater, music,
to fight in the struggle.
And in "The Lion King," I'll
always find a similar situation
whereby Nala has to
run away to regroup
to fight against the hyenas
when they've taken the kingdom,
and eventually find Simba
and come back with Simba,
and rally the troops, and
fight, and eventually reclaim
the kingdom from the hyenas.
And to me it's always
been a signature
that South Africa
in 1994, we voted
for the first black
president, Nelson Mandela.
And that always bring-- because
we left South Africa when
things were still really harsh.
And I remember when they
left, we were really young,
we thought we were never
going to see them again.
You know, we come right after.
And when I left South
Africa, when you come back,
you still had to go
through a lot of grilling
as to where have you been,
who did you speak to,
what did you do?
And that, to me, is always
a reminder to myself
that through all of
that, the country today
is in a better state.
So it does relate to what
everyone is going through.
And given the state of
the different democracies
in the world, you eventually
come in a full circle
into how things
are supposed to be.
That's the story.
CHRIS JACKSON: I think
that's a wonderful segue.
At this time, it's time
for another number, y'all.
You ready for that?
[APPLAUSE]
Can we welcome Joel Karie
and Adrienne Walker, Simba
and Nala, singing "Can You
Feel the Love Tonight."
[MUSIC - "CAN YOU FEEL THE LOVE
TONIGHT"]
CHRIS JACKSON: Y'all so good.
Wasn't that good?
Nearly 300 South
African performers
have worked on "The Lion
King" around the world
for the past 20 years.
We're lucky to have
four of them today.
I'd love to hear from all
of you about the impact--
the South African performers--
in South African
culture on the show.
And especially the four of
our South African brothers
and sisters, what your
experiences with the show
have been like.
LINDIWE DLAMINI: For
me, being able to sing
South African music in these
audiences all over the world,
and it brings all these
beautiful harmonies that we
known for as South Africans.
We are known for singing
beautiful harmonies.
So "The Lion King" brings
that to these audiences
all over the world.
And the fact that now
they have employed
so many thousands,
thousands of young people
from South Africa who
have never gotten a chance
to go to an international
stage and perform.
So that's what "Lion King"
brings for my people.
CHRIS JACKSON: Now, did
you also participate
in the "Sarafina" production?
LINDIWE DLAMINI: Yes.
When I first came
in this country,
I was in the show called
"Sarafina" during apartheid,
which was different.
Because that show was
more about the struggle,
it was just a heavy show.
It was sad, you know, we were
just fighting for our freedom.
So we were more like the
ambassadors of South Africa
to come here and tell the
world what was going on.
And now I enjoy being
in "The Lion King"
because the music is exciting,
it's uplifting people,
it's happy music.
So for me, those are two
different experiences,
and I enjoyed being here and
be able to just experience
this with everybody.
TSHIDI MANYE: One
other thing that
makes me laugh all the time is
that when the audience comes in
and they ask you a question like
well is what you're singing,
is it real?
Is it a real language?
That clicking thing, you
always do a great lip syncing.
No, it's a real language.
MICHAEL HENRY: Do it for them.
Do it for them.
CHRIS JACKSON: I think you
have to do a little bit.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
JOEL KARIE: Don't clap,
that's her actual language.
That's just her talking,
it's not that impressive.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS JACKSON: She just
gave you her grocery list
and that's all.
BONGI DUMA: I mean, on
the other side of it,
I think it is important--
I always highlight this.
Because for most of us--
I mean, I think the
four of us here--
none of us have actually went
to a music school, or a theater,
or anything.
We've never went
to school for that.
I said LA was a tool for us
to fight against the struggle.
And for most of the
singers, and actors,
and dancers, South Africa,
singing and dancing
is not really a job.
It is a hobby.
Half the country
knows how to sing.
So when you go up
on stage, it's not
like they want to
be entertained.
They want to judge you.
Because at least
someone there is
waiting to tell you that, oh,
I can do that better than you.
And if you say, can you?
They say, try me.
And they will literally
come up and prove that.
It is a beauty that we have that
we grow up hearing this music,
because there are songs
culturally for everything that
are written by random people.
I mean, they are
mostly public domain
so we grew up hearing
these harmonies whenever
there's anything.
That's why sometimes
it's a little offensive,
but it is reality whenever we
see African kids on television,
they're dancing, and
happy, and singing.
It is how we grow up.
That's how we grew up.
If you take it out of the
political context and just
look at it, and if you go to
Africa, the first thing you see
will be children following
and chasing after the car
seeing a person and
singing and dancing.
And if you ask why
they're dancing,
sometimes there's no
explanation, it's just joy.
So most of us, this is amazing
that you calling me-- you
putting me on a plane
and you telling me
that you're going to pay
me for singing and dancing.
So I mean, it's amazing.
And all these 300 people,
it's amazing to us
that from the side
of art perspective
that we have been
able to get jobs
that we will not
get in South Africa.
Just because they can just
grab anybody and just put them
in something, you know.
So it's very special to us,
and we'll always appreciate it.
And I have to highlight that.
When "Lion King"
started, South Africans
were supposed to be
only for six months
and go, and leave the country.
And Julie Taymor together
with Tom Schumacher and that
cast of--
the American cast, actors
and dancers, they fought.
They say, if these people
leave, we are not doing this.
And that's how we got to stay
as South Africans in the show,
people like him and the rest
of the original cast members
fought to make sure that
we remain in the show.
And that we are
forever grateful to you
guys and everybody else
who come and see the show.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS JACKSON: You can cut
me a check when we're done.
[LAUGHTER]
Joking.
Not really.
A lot of talk about diversity
in casting, obviously.
With shows like
"Hamilton," that certainly
is one of the first
things that comes to mind,
because the founding
fathers weren't black.
But what you just
alluded to, people
don't realize that The "Lion
King" was at the forefront
when it comes to diverse
casting on Broadway.
One of the things
that comes to mind
is when I graduated
from college in '95,
there were only two
shows that I could
have been cast in on Broadway.
And one of them was would
have been because my face,
I could have been
painted in "Cats,"
but nobody was trying
to dance like that.
And then "Showboat"
was the other show.
And they weren't trying to
cast me as no riverboat slave,
because I was too light.
Then "Lion King" comes along.
And it's the longest
running black show--
predominantly
African-American show--
in the history of Broadway.
I know that because
of the Disney name
it's not commonly-- it's
not assumed that that is
a characterization of the show.
But not only is it predominantly
African-American and South
African, I've always
found that the show
serves as a beacon of light for
young performers of color who
are coming out of
these amazing programs
and don't really have a show
that they can look to and say,
I'm going to be on Broadway,
I want to be in that show.
That's a place for me.
And I think that
Broadway's gone a long way
to start the
process of including
more and more actors of color.
JOEL KARIE: It's actually
very interesting you
say that because I'm actually
on the Chris Jackson track.
So 20 years later, I do his job
that he did when he first came.
CHRIS JACKSON: Oh, really?
JOEL KARIE: Yeah,
exactly, I'm your track.
And it is the same thing.
I was just slightly behind Chris
in age when it came to casting.
But at least I did
have "The Lion King"
because there was that.
When I was in
school when I first
started undergraduate
and learning theater,
people didn't quite know
where to place me either.
Because you'd go into a casting,
and they would always say,
can you be a bit more urban?
Like that's always like--
there's certain-- or,
we want to do it again,
but a little more street.
You know what I mean?
So there wasn't a
lot of diversity
even within the type of roles
you could be considered for.
And then "Lion King" came
along and changed that
for a lot of people.
And you can see
the ripple effects
almost immediately if you
just look at years following
on Broadway casting.
All of a sudden you're getting
called in for different types
of roles.
And all of a sudden you
were being considered
for a whole array of
characters that you weren't
seen just the year before.
It was incredible.
CHRIS JACKSON: I think that
the future will bear this out.
But a young Lin
Miranda saw me as Simba
two years before he
graduated college.
I have to believe that
every time a young--
especially a young artist,
or a young producer,
or a young casting director--
someone who hasn't established
themselves yet--
comes to see a show and
has a moving experience,
it expands their horizon
of possibilities.
So that when they do get into
the place of their career--
place of influence,
their place of employment
in a company such as this, it
broadens their perspective.
And it gives everyone
just a more realistic view
of what the world looks like.
I think that's obviously
art at its best, right?
I want to get to the funny stuff
that happens behind the scenes.
Because everybody always
wants to know what
happens when a giraffe falls
going across the savanna.
MICHAEL HENRY: I have a
funny story about that one.
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah,
please, share, share.
Yes, please.
MICHAEL HENRY: So we have two
dancers who portrayed giraffes.
And in order to get dressed in
them, they are put on a ladder
and stilts are put on
their arms and their legs.
CHRIS JACKSON: And
they're attached, right?
MICHAEL HENRY: And
they're attached,
like you can't get out of them.
So they're in the last
number, all the way
through the last number,
and in the bows as well.
So I guess this one guy was
feeling a bit extra that day.
And he started rearing up,
and he went back and fell
on his flailing back like this.
And there's nothing you can
do, so the stage manager
comes on, grabs him, pulls him
offstage, curtain comes down.
CHRIS JACKSON: Any
other things come
to mind that might
be good for a giggle?
Number
LINDIWE DLAMINI: I remember,
because usually they
track the giraffes and
whatever that fell on stage.
One day I fell on stage.
And then what happened is
when we sing one by one,
you know, the second act, these
costumes are so long, so long.
Like you had to lift them up
when you go off the stage.
For some reason that day I
was into myself, and just
happy, and excited,
walking up the stairs.
And then I tripped
on the costume.
And I'm the last
person to go on stage.
And that moment I
fall on the stage.
And this costume
is under my legs.
And I'm trying to
get up, I'm trying--
and it's the silk.
So I'm trying to get up, I'm
looking at-- he's my husband,
and he was singing on stage.
I'm looking so he can get me.
But he's like-- so
he was like, no, I'm
singing my solo right now.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm looking, I'm like
looking around, I'm like,
oh my God, I can't get
this costume off my feet.
So I'm wrapped around
and I see the stage man,
[INAUDIBLE] I'm
like, I can't leave.
So finally I get off the
stage, we got downstairs
in the bunker, everybody,
you could hear a pin drop.
Everybody didn't know, they
wanted to laugh so hard at me,
but everybody's
looking if I'm OK.
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah, they
did the check, is she hurt?
If she's hurt it's not funny.
LINDIWE DLAMINI: When
I started laughing,
everybody started laughing.
And they said I look like
the commercial, I'm falling,
I can't get up.
But I was OK, I was OK.
But I never fell again.
CHRIS JACKSON: Oh,
that's fantastic.
OK, I think at this point
we're going to open up
the floor for some questions.
Do any of you guys
have any questions
for this wonderful cast?
Y'all know everything.
Y'all are full from
eating too much at lunch.
Hi.
Please give us your name
and ask your question.
JESS: Hi, I'm Jess.
Thank you so much for coming,
this has been amazing.
So I work on our
people operations team,
which is what we call
HR, human resources.
And we spend a lot
of time thinking
about how we build
really effective teams,
and how we make people
feel included and welcome,
especially when their
new to an organization.
Are there any norms
or things that you
do when you have
new cast members
come in to try and create,
like, a cohesive team?
BONGI DUMA: I don't
know, but maybe this
will work for your team.
I'm going to share
this with you.
So in my dressing room,
so my dressing room
is split into two.
It's singers on the
other side, and there's
dancers on the other side.
So right off when you
go up in this board
that's in there is the
heels with different sizes
of high heel shoes.
JOEL KARIE: The men.
BONGI DUMA: The men, the
men, high heel shoes.
So what happens that
when you're new,
we make you believe that
everyone who's in the room
has actually put
on these high heels
and actually walk all
around the dressing room.
So what happened is that
this is just a way of--
we want to see if you are brave
enough to embarrass yourself
or to entertain us.
Because that way we've
got some [INAUDIBLE]..
So we all-- usually
when half hour comes,
everybody goes and warm up.
And maybe there's
two or three people.
When you're coming
in here a new person,
we wait for the stage manager
to bring you to introduce you,
and we ask ask them to leave.
And then we put
the pop music on,
we let you try the
high heels, and then
you've got to walk around
the room just in pumps,
just you have to go up.
And if you're a
little tight, we've
got a couple of guys that
already in the high heels
to show you what
you're supposed to do.
So I mean, I think you
might just try that.
I mean, might
work, I don't know.
JESS: I'll raise this
with our executives.
CHRIS JACKSON: That's a
good team builder, right?
AUDIENCE: One of the things
that I love about the show
so much is that
along with, I think,
only Paul Simon's
"Graceland," it's
the best example of putting
South African music in front
of a mainstream audience.
And I know for the South
African performance,
that's just kind of
what you mentioned,
it's just another day.
But for the non Africans, was
there any adjusting period
getting used to those
funky harmonies, maybe
some other stuff that you
weren't really familiar with?
BONGI DUMA: They asked us--
oh, non-South Africans.
CHRIS JACKSON:
Pick one, you have
to be either South African
or non-South African, OK?
MICHAEL HENRY: I'll start.
When I started--
I started a while ago.
I've been in
different companies.
I started, I think, in 2003.
They had this thing where
they were doing master classes
before you got cast.
So you would come in
for like six weeks,
I think, and they
would teach you
a little bit of the language,
they would teach you
some of the songs.
So by the time I
got into the show,
I think I learned the
show in two weeks.
So it was a bit easier for me.
I don't know what the
process is for you guys.
CHRIS JACKSON: I understood the
harmonic structure of it all,
but marrying that
with the language
was extremely taxing vocally.
And I went home
after the third day--
of course, we were singing
for about four hours
in the morning, and then we
were moving in the afternoon.
Everybody there had already
had a master class of some sort
or had done the workshop.
I had never even heard--
I'd seen the movie, but I
hadn't sung any of it, you know.
So there are certain
African-American vocal
traditions in the
church that you
will find a lot of the same
harmonic structures there.
But linguistically
speaking, my chords
were bleeding by the time the
second or third day was there.
And I had--
I was fresh.
But I just didn't know
how to pace myself
inside that kind of music.
And it took a while.
But once I got into it,
I remember it so vividly.
But once I got into it, it
started to flow a lot easier.
Any more questions?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you
so much for being here.
I am the biggest fan--
OK, maybe not the biggest.
But I am a huge fan.
I have a five-year-old daughter.
The minute she
turned three, I had
to have her watch
"The Lion King."
Because it's such a great story
and still resonates so much.
So I guess my
question is, we are
in jobs where we
are not facing so
many people on a daily basis.
And you know, there are days
when I don't like what I do,
and it's OK.
You have to be on
stage and you have
to entertain regardless
of how you feel.
So what do you do when
you're not in the mood?
What are those tricks?
CHRIS JACKSON: Good question.
MDU MADELA: I couldn't wait
to answer that question.
The thing is, this
is the motivation.
You look at faces
while you-- we are
fortunate that we have
a show where everything
doesn't start backstage.
The show starts, half of the
people who are in the cast,
they start within the audience.
So the moment you enter,
you already feel the vibe.
There's no way in me that I
would say I'm tired today,
I cannot do it.
It just takes you looking
at two or three people
within the audience
and that's it.
That's it.
NTELISENG NHKELA:
And yes, of course,
sometimes you come to work
and just like normal people,
you tired, and you don't
feel like doing it.
But what motivates you more like
we open the show walking down
the aisle.
And you see those faces
happy and some of them
crying because of
just happiness,
I'm seeing all the animals.
It motivates you to
just want to do this
more and more with a good
spirit and happiness.
TSHIDI MANYE: The
other funny thing
is, I know that a
lot of people when
they come to see this show, they
think that it's a kid's show.
But it's one thing when you
come, the curtain goes up
and you start singing,
and you're seeing dads
being the one crying.
And like, oh my God,
look at the-- oh, my God,
just like little kids.
It motivates you,
you know, makes
us think that you're
doing something great.
MICHAEL HENRY: I'd say
also our other actors.
We have a lot of
different social cues
that we'll do with each other
backstage basically every day.
It's like, if I don't do that
social cue with an actor,
they'll be so angry with me.
So you know, the other actors
will definitely lift you up
if you're not feeling it.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
I'm definitely one of those
people who's like, yay, look!
Thank you.
CHRIS JACKSON: I think
that theater in general
provides a framework
by which when
you take the discipline that
you develop during a show,
you fall into a
rhythm with that.
And there's comfort
in that rhythm.
And you can know what to expect.
So that when you
have a cold, or when
you have a pulled hamstring,
or it's just like a baseball
player taking swings
in the cage, like,
there's just something
about the routine of it
all that puts you in the
place that you need to do it.
And because we're
expressing ourselves,
there's also a great
release, a great catharsis
that happens by just going
through and allowing yourself
to feel what you're
feeling, and tell the story,
and be as dedicated
to it as you can.
We have time for
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm actually
visiting from the San Francisco
Bay Area, and I'm here today.
So I like got in at
6:00 this morning.
CHRIS JACKSON: This
is all for you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
My question is, so when I
was younger I was actually--
I wanted to be like you guys.
I wanted to be on
Broadway, but now I'm here.
So my question
is, what would you
tell a young aspiring
actor, especially
like an actor of color, what
would you tell them to never
give up on their dreams
if they were trying
to pursue this type of career?
JOEL KARIE: I always
say to young people
when I work with them
that everything you learn
is important.
I am the opposite of you.
I went to school
for computer science
originally and
switched to theater.
Because they didn't take
back my scholarship.
CHRIS JACKSON: That's
just too meta, I can't.
JOEL KARIE: So
like that's spooky.
But also, as a
young person I had
immigrant parents who they're
like, you will do everything.
You play instruments,
you will speak languages,
you will do all these
different things.
Because we're in America
and we're going to do well!
So all those classes and things
that I took, I never really
thought would be important.
But the great
thing about theater
is it's so collaborative.
It's only a matter of time
before a show comes along
that is going to need
your expertise in coding,
or in playing the saxophone.
I mean, when "Lion
King" started,
we didn't think
that there would be
a hugely successful rap-based
musical about the founding
of this nation.
You know what I mean?
Like it's only a matter of time.
So you have to be
when you're young--
or when you're not--
throughout your whole life,
you have to be a sponge and
constantly absorb and take
every opportunity it has given
to you to grow and to learn.
Because it will be applicable
to art at some point.
Because that's what
makes art great.
That's what keeps it changing.
CHRIS JACKSON: Broadway is the
pinnacle of commerce and art
sort of crashing
into one another.
So it's a very specific thing.
I tell anyone, no matter what
line of work that you're in,
pursue your passion.
So if performing is something
that you care about,
and that's something that you
just wake up in the morning,
(SINGING) I got to do this,
go to work, pay your bills,
but there are lots of
places to be an artist.
There's lots of different
ways to do that.
There are lots of communities
that completely welcome that.
And I know especially
in the Bay Area,
there's 100 theaters out there.
Get your life, man.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS JACKSON: So Guys,
It's time for another song.
As we kind of, just like in
the show, kind of wrap it up,
we're going to do a little
"Circle of Life," I think.
What do y'all think, y'all
ready to do a little "Circle
of Life?"
Think we could do that.
Can we just give it up
another round of applause
for our amazing panelists?
[MUSIC - "CIRCLE OF LIFE"]
Give it up for the cast
of "The Lion King," also
for our amazing band,
Dave [INAUDIBLE]
on bass, Matt "Lefty" Black
on guitar, Gary [INAUDIBLE]
on drums, and on piano,
music director and arranger
Jim Abbot.
Ladies and gentlemen,
"The Lion King."